yeah this is the first sign that George Santos has
recognized that that he could be in some trouble
here remember he has been defiant all along saying
that he's done nothing wrong he's got nothing to
hide say he would not resign moving forward as a
normal member of Congress despite admitting to a
number of Lies facing investigations questions
about his campaign Finance new revelation that
seemed to come out almost daily that have hurt
this battle Congressman threatened his career
here in Congress now telling his conference
behind closed doors that he will not serve on
two key committees committee assignments that were
actually given to him by the Speaker of the House
along with his top allies despite some pushback of
concerns that he would sit on these committees he
made very clear just moments ago to his conference
that he would sit and step aside until these legal
issues are resolved that is the Senate that's
a house small business committee as well as the
house science committee neither of those committee
plans to participate in until these matters have
resolved with satisfaction and he told the speaker
about this decision last night and congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor green who had just caught up
with indicated how Santos's message was received
he just felt like um there's drama really over
the situation and especially what what we're
doing to work to remove illness committee he
said that this was a decision that he made
now that was in reference to the effort
by the House Republicans are trying to
remove congresswoman ilahan Omar from
the house Foreign Affairs committee the
Democrat from Minnesota for her past
remarks the there have been criticism
from Democrats that they're allowing Santos
to serve on these committees but trying to
oust Omar from hers but Santa's making it
clear to his members that he doesn't want
to undercut their efforts to try to remove
Omar that requires a vote of the Full House